Hey,
what's going on is bill burr and it's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast in,
Huh?
Ah,
I'm
just checking in on you.
I'm just checking in on you.
How did your week gone to this fucking Thursday stairs,
da geocode fucking payday.
I'll,
you'd paid on Friday.
Well,
fuck you and your job,
man.
I used to get paid on Thursday.
I skipped paid on Thursday and I used to keep my money.
I used to have my money.
I spent it on bay.
Well,
where do you want to go?
Who's it up to?
May allow me dependent.
She got nothing.
My life was mine and that 260 bucks a week that I made.
I had a fucking car payment for $138 a month.
I was rolling in it,
you know,
fucking rolling in it.
I didn't even realize it.
I was like,
Oh gee,
wouldn't it be great someday to fucking get out there in the world,
get my own place,
have a car,
drive down the street,
man.
Right.
What happens?
You get out there and you fucking you.
You're just stupid.
You like a little toddler walking,
crawling up to a fucking Cobra and they forgot to so its mouth shut,
you know,
like,
cause they do that shit over in India,
you know,
we just born into a family of snake charmers whatever happens over,
they haven't seen that video.
I assumed it was an India,
you know,
and don't get mad at me.
Blame Hollywood.
All right.
I've hung out with disease a few times.
I never,
I never brought the Cobra thing up.
I forgot to find out if this was true or not.
I could have been like a Z,
Z is this or is this not a your people things specifically.
And then he could have been like,
God no built is actually this snake charmers all over uh,
all over the world.
You know what?
I would've said it.
What's it?
Fair enough.
But I didn't.
So anyway,
she ever seen those fucking videos where they,
they,
so the goddamn cobras fucking mouth shut.
Can I curse more than that sentence?
Have you seen those?
Um,
have you seen that footage where they take the unknown and I went at this point
with this voice,
I'd have to know the Latin name for Cobra.
They sold the fucking things mouth shut and then they have a baby crawl up to it
and the,
and the snake,
it's like freaking out because you're going to understand is small as a baby,
as to a person for snake,
it's still pretty fucking big.
Like what?
What is,
what is that?
Is that a mongoose?
Is that going to run up and just grabbed my face and give me a couple of shakes
and then that's it.
Last thing I see in my life is,
is the inside of a fucking Mongooses esophagus.
That's what the snake is thinking.
It's just a snake only has one fucking expression.
You know,
reptiles are like redefine resting bitch face
reptiles never look like they're in a good mood.
Oh,
they're just stay or they just have like,
no,
they just kind of fucking sitting there like a frog.
Right?
It's not a fucking reptile and amphibian.
Well,
whatever it is,
doesn't have any hair on it.
They have a little bit,
oh,
that was less cool.
Less clean clothes line.
Right.
It's talking about some woman's said she was finer than frog hair.
Um,
what the fuck song was that?
That was one of his solo albums.
His bucket of Bernie brains,
something of the hunt.
I can't remember how my brain's going.
Oh,
I would,
I don't know where to start.
I was talking about babies fucking messing with,
with,
uh,
cobras.
I Dunno,
I got there.
I mean,
what's going on?
How many minutes just went by three 42 just like that.
Just like that.
Three 42 you drive home and you drive to work.
Right?
Well maybe you have really tiny headphones and your wife's bitching at you right
now and you listen to this.
Oh,
your boyfriend.
I Dunno.
I Dunno what the fuck he's doing.
Um,
yeah,
he had that dream that you're going to go out in the real world and your money
was going to be made and it was going to go into your pocket.
And Dude,
I'm going to have a fucking keg rater over here.
Fucking pool table Air Hockey.
And what happens?
Okay.
20 years goes by,
20 years way they go 20 years,
I don't know.
Right Bob Seger.
Sometimes I sit and wonder where they gone.
Passmart is Bob Seger.
Bob Seger was smart enough to realize that most people lose and he sang right to
those fuckers and they showed up with their fucking,
what are the,
what does that old Milwaukee threatened?
They sat right in the front row at the bottom,
lips quivering,
you know,
and then the wise would look over like,
oh honey,
what's the matter?
And then they'd have to slap their wife cause you,
you couldn't show that you cried back then when the song first came up.
Now you can sit there with like cupcakes and kittens on your shirt as a man.
Sit there.
Indian style wearing yoga pants and your wife,
you know,
I don't know what she's doing.
She's got work boots on and a trucker hat.
I don't know what goes on with the youth today.
I don't pretend to know I'm an older person.
All right.
All I know is somehow all the bands went into the computer and they never came
out again.
And then they just became one person.
You know,
like Mayweather says form like Voltron,
right?
Doesn't vultron like one guy.
I know what the fuck it is.
Wow.
The hell would they?
I mean I'm from the age of like,
I mean I was too old for stomp or four by fours when they came out.
That's how I played with Tonka trucks.
People.
Okay.
There was no batteries and nothing thing.
You wanted it to move.
You had to fucking push it.
All right?
And you wrote those things down the driveway and right before it went into
traffic,
you bailed off of it and you prayed to God that it would make the other side
without getting run over by a milk truck.
Right.
There you go.
So
and like you,
I also don't know what I'm talking about at this point anyways.
Yeah,
you thought it was going to be all yours.
I mean 20 years fucking goes by.
Okay.
And then one day you walk a d and you're just looking around at all the shit and
all it really is,
it's,
it's just a bunch of shit.
What's the,
what is all this shit?
Fucking tables and couches chair.
We're going to fucking chairs here.
How many kids do we plan on having?
Why are there so many God damn chairs.
One others.
This is a perfect area right here where a drunk kid could go.
You know what does that stupid picture?
Why don't you take it off the wall and put up a fucking dad?
I just feel like that wouldn't look right.
Be kind of awkward.
Why would that be awkward?
You know,
it's an awkward,
every room.
Vaguely looking the same.
We look like we live in a furniture store.
There's nothing in here but furniture.
How about some fun shit?
What about that game where you try to punch it as hard as you can to see how
strong you are?
You know where that game would you shoot the baskets.
You can't just have one of those.
I don't know.
I just feel like that was,
you know,
maybe in the garage.
Is there a way to put it behind the house and down the street?
I don't want to have company over and have them see that you're having fun.
I want
my wife fed it out.
Listen to this.
I want them to come over and see that you are totally in control under my
control and you are,
you are listening to the fucking decisions that I want to make.
I'm just fucking with you.
Um,
anyways,
whatever.
Most of that isn't true.
Only the sad part.
Um,
it starts to everybody either get paid today or tomorrow.
What do you do with your money?
Huh?
But he didn't do it in here.
Bank of America.
Evidentaly they were entire fucking system was down.
How does that happen?
That's not scary enough as it Jesus Christ.
I hope they didn't.
You know,
I should look that up.
I should look that up before I cause a run on a bank.
Is that the name of a song run on a bank?
Is that a Bob Seger Song?
Was that ain't no surprise.
Oh,
that's love on the rocks.
Not Run on a bank.
Love on the rocks.
Ain't no big surprise that it was run on a bank
grabbing by their ties.
Especially with him.
Milk,
white fucking thighs.
Why does my Internet suck?
And every fucking room,
I swear to God,
who am I Internet company is they have to have a poster me on the wall.
Go.
We need more customers like this.
He pays 10 times what he should fucking pay.
It never works.
And he never complains unless he's doing his podcast.
But who gives a fuck?
Cause he never calls us.
So what do we care?
We just keep taking his fucking money.
All right,
here we go.
Bank of America.
Fuck yeah.
Everyone in the world is jealous of us.
Everyone wants to be just like us.
That's why they hate on us.
All right.
Maybe.
Maybe we've gotten out of the line in a few areas.
All right.
Evidently it's loading.
You know what I mean?
Watching my computer tried to get on the Internet,
like waiting for it for load.
It's like watching me try to remember shit from fucking two days ago.
Oh you sneaky fucking bastards.
This isn't what I wanted.
I didn't want you to a website.
I wanted to fucking gossip.
What am I gonna hit?
Bank of America Slash TMZ.
Bank of fucking America.
Here we go again.
Bank of America.
Okay,
Google.
Here we go.
What do you got?
What do we got?
Yeah.
Customers shat out of accounts during a parent Bank of America outage.
Okay.
Oh boy.
I'm just picturing someone with one of those.
What's that?
White masks that those PR fucking hackers where when they want to shut down the
corporations.
Um,
all right,
here we go.
Bank of America customers was shut out from their accounts.
Oh,
an advertisement.
Ralph's.
Jesus.
You know what?
I will buy a Honeywell am.
All right.
Well,
Bac Bank of America customers were shut out from their accounts for several
hours.
Wednesday in a system outage.
You know,
somebody who's fucking,
you know,
didn't get dialysis so their heart stops.
So you would,
you wouldn't,
he was such with,
with so at the feet of these fucking cunts,
coral springs resident,
Eric's,
oh,
he's asleep or you'd never think he could run that fast.
And those work boots and there he goes down the street.
So we got what looked like a phishing email from the bank Wednesday and
immediately started calling customer service to see if something was wrong,
a message on his online accounts that it could not pull up his information.
When we called,
his local branch of managers said that the local managers are calling each other
trying to figure out what caused
what appeared to be a national outage and why they were unable to provide
certain services like what provides you with the money that you need.
Um,
on down detector.com,
a website that tracks reports,
have system outages report started spiking after 11:30 AM and the website was
inundated with comments from Bank of American customers don't what the fuck send
around the country saying they couldn't access online banking computers.
Transit did it by 1:00 PM they had received nearly 1000 reports of problems,
but by Wednesday evening all although some customers were still reporting
problems that never reports had gone down considerably to about 200 and then
this is their common.
I know that the tape is working quickly to bring everything back up and as time
progresses they should be able to go back online.
I would really love to see what really happened.
A Bank of American system wide system wide outage on the damn closing on my
closing on my house and there's nothing I can do about it.
Bank of America,
you closed my bank account with no notice.
How can I deposit my check when I no longer have an account stuck in Thailand?
Okay.
What is up with not being able to transfer system has been down for three hours.
Oh Jesus.
Jenny.
That's nothing compared to the guy stuck in Thailand.
The clerk at Bank of America just said,
I can't make it to cock deposit because a nationwide disruption.
Anyone know what's up?
All right.
Yeah.
Okay.
All right,
well let's just soap.
That was a onetime thing.
Nothing to see here.
That's fucking scary.
That's why you gotta have your money in like three different banks.
I don't care if you get 40 bucks,
but 15 and one 10 and another.
What do we got left,
Dan?
What's that?
25 you can 15.
The last one,
right?
1515 yes.
10.
It's a fucking shell game out there,
man.
Um,
then when you got to pay your rent,
you write three different checks.
Why don't you just write it for the full amount?
Okay.
Cause I'm not going to get stuck in Thailand.
You can't,
what do you care?
As long as it all works.
Um,
all right,
let's get back to a,
the podcast here.
Um,
I am,
when you listen to this,
I will be in New York City by the time you listen to this.
I am going to the airport to not to not to that.
Um,
I'm going back to New York.
Yeah.
For about a week.
I'm going to be there for a week.
Week.
I'm doing an acting gig out there.
As I mentioned before,
they rebooting sex in the city and a,
I'm going to be playing this,
Cynthia Nixon,
Karen,
uh,
they said to keep my head shaved.
Maybe they could do some sort of,
I dunno,
post,
uh,
you know,
cancer free.
Uh,
I guess Craig Nixon,
I don't know my fucking name is going to be,
but you know,
I want it to be the,
the fabulous one.
Whatever the fuck her name is.
What the fuck was her name?
I saw him one time at a Knicks game.
She'll still look beautiful,
you know,
but they're thin fucking head,
she needs more head and I need less said.
If we could somehow combine the two of us,
I think,
you know,
they could have something there.
The fuck is her name.
She started it.
How do you remember Cynthia Nixon and you don't remember the other one?
Sarah.
Jessica.
That's right.
S J p she had a fucking basketball shoe.
How about those red sox won in the last three out of four.
Yeah.
That shit
went to,
went to against the fucking yaggies all where then we,
uh,
took two or three from the Blue Jays.
I watched the whole blue Jay series.
I enjoy,
you know what's great is a Dennis Eckersley up in the booth.
The man loves the game.
The man played the game.
The man can talk the game.
God dammit.
He does it for nine innings.
I love,
especially when it's like a low scoring game.
If you have a fucking picture up there,
he's incredible.
They'll actually make it exciting.
Think he's going to kill me with the fucking,
I go breaking ball here.
Guy Throws a breaking ball.
He's like,
get this guy that he's like,
it's like he has fucking ESP.
It's like he pitched in the fucking league.
Everybody.
How does this man know what happens if gently the Yankees made some sort of move
to,
to cock block the red sox.
But you know,
I tried to get annoyed by that,
but you know,
it's been three world series.
I think we're good.
It gives a shit.
We're in first place.
I think it's kind of over.
I think the Yankees Red sox thing is,
it'll never be what it was and I'm happy for it.
I'm actually glad that it won't be,
I don't miss it.
Okay.
Because uh,
yeah,
you know,
it usually didn't work out.
It worked out for us once
and then it was over.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
oh by the way,
still in posted a picture of my drum kit.
I swear to God.
You know,
I'm going to fucking send it right now,
so I'm going to send it right fucking now.
You probably already see it by the time this things posted.
Let me just fucking,
it's not the greatest picture.
I was by myself.
What do you want from me?
Come on.
Oh Shit.
You know,
I was reading something the other day.
I'm going to give to it.
Um,
about good fellas.
It was this really cool thing that said 30 things you might not know about
Goodfellas and it's actually 30 things that I didn't fucking know.
Um,
even though they still talked about how,
uh,
how am I funny?
What do I amuse you?
What am I,
some sort of clown.
Everybody knows that that was Improv,
but like passion,
those guys was saying we would improv it and then he,
he would write it all down and then,
you know,
take the best parts in that write it down.
Then you had to memorize it,
then you'd fucking go do it,
which makes sense because you can't like fucking improv every different taken
that he moves to cameras around you saying different Shit that you did the other
time and then it's not,
it's not going to line up.
So anyways,
he was,
it was the best one of the best ones.
Um,
that whole tracking scene where,
um,
Henry Hill takes Karen,
what did you,
oh,
you just killed us.
Okay.
Sorry.
Right.
Um,
he takes her in through the kitchen.
Right.
That whole tracking shot.
And that was one sentence in the book that Scorsese got this idea.
There's a,
there's a line in that book wise guy or whatever the fuck the one that Henry
Hill road it said,
um,
on crowded nights when people were lined up outside and couldn't get in the
doorman used to let Henry,
I'm sorry,
the prince really small.
My eyes are gone.
You still led Henry and our party in through the kitchen,
which was filled with Chinese cooks and we go upstairs and sit down immediately.
That one sentence in that poll fucking book.
Yeah.
I mean,
how many times did you read that book?
He just read it one time and said,
oh,
that gives me an idea.
Bam.
Um,
you'd think it would at least be a paragraph.
Yeah,
some sort of story attached to it.
It's just one God damn sentence
and that guy's fucking able to do all of that.
And that my friends is why he's one of the great directors and all time.
All right,
let's,
let's get a good one here.
Let's get a good one.
Three d,
d d d,
d.
Oh,
there we go.
There we go.
Symbols that are fucked up angle.
I had to run out of there.
I'm a dad now.
It's like whenever I get a fucking chance,
I run over there.
I ran over there this morning.
I literally played four songs and then went to work.
I didn't stretch it all cause I didn't have time to and then my fucking forearms
and tans were all fucked up.
I'm an idiot.
All right,
let me send this right now.
You guys are literally listening to me.
Send a fucking picture.
Uh
Oh guests who wants to come back?
Guess who wants to come back
after after fucking dumping this podcast guest.
Who wants to come back?
Huh?
After it's not nature's box.
Okay.
It's a hold on a second.
Post this with podcast.
You can't,
I didn't say that.
Alright.
Guess the draft kings wants to come back with a fuck the day go Tom.
What the fuck is wrong with ya?
Um,
did you hear what's his face got?
'Em they're going to be backed by the way,
cause they said,
I can say whatever the fuck I watch,
which means I can make the advertising is funny as I want.
This means you guys will listen and then you go.
That's all that's all advertising is just get people to listen and maybe
somebody will buy.
Um,
there was a rumor I heard
that,
um,
what's his face?
Klarna condom.
Glenna Macgregor got knocked out by your sparring partner.
And A,
I looked it up and what I loved was made,
whether it was like,
I don't believe it until I see footage,
I don't believe it.
Like maybe that was a strategy by my,
um,
McGregor and it kind of all got fucking just explained away like,
no,
it didn't happen.
So there you go.
There's one for you guys who are still going to order it.
There was no proof.
It was debunked by number Gregor camp may weather wasn't.
That does not believe it.
So there's still a chance,
there's some stupid article out there calling Conor McGregor yet another great
white hope.
It's like,
this is not another great white hope.
Great White Hope would be if he was an actual inboxing,
trying to win a fucking title.
You know,
this guy holds two titles.
He already is a champion.
Okay.
He already has a champion,
you know,
when it's not a whites only league.
So I don't know.
He's a great white hope.
This is a fucking spectacle.
That's what this is too.
God Damn Spectacle.
I am gonna try so fucking hard to order it already agreed with Rogan.
Then I might watch it the next week with them.
He does his thing.
When you've just fucking watch it together and you talk about it.
I might do that with Rogan.
If I can find some goddamn time to do it,
I have to do it.
Um,
that's also a good way to watch it for free,
for free.
Um,
maybe that's what I'll do.
I'll be the fucking grumpy guy that didn't watch it and then I'll solo watch it
and really just a tight fuck.
I'm going to watch it for free.
Remember that expression fucking ante up yet tight.
Fuck.
Hey,
does anybody know how the expression,
uh,
on the arm came about?
We tried to figure that out today in the writer's room.
Meaning it's for free.
The Best I could get is that it's,
it's a policemen slang on the arm and all I could think was,
you know,
the long arm of the law,
the arm of the law.
Why is why,
how does the expression on the arm,
okay,
calm about what is the origin?
That means it's free.
Don't pay for these drinks there on the arm.
Can anybody tell me,
cause people already told me p's and q's.
Mind your own ps and Qs came from the bars and the pubs where they used to give
beer in pints and courts.
So when people got a little,
you know,
out of line and sticking their nose in other people's business or getting ready
to fight a mind,
your p's and q's,
you'll look at your fucking glass.
You don't look at anybody else or whatever the fuck it meant.
Right.
So I liked that shit.
So if he can tell me how long the arm came about,
I don't give a shit.
If you make up stuff,
I'll read it like it's,
it's a fact,
then it'll end up on Wikipedia and then at least people will have an answer.
Um,
anyways,
so these fucking Toronto Blue Jay fans would talk and shit,
cause I actually watched that whole fucking 14 any game,
um,
where Hanley Ramirez hit the walk off home run,
right?
It was three,
three after regulation and then 13,
um,
after nine innings,
whatever the fuck you saying this sport and then,
and like the 12th inning or something like that,
Blue Jay scored a run,
went up four to three and then we somehow scored a run,
made it four to four.
And then Hanley Ramirez in the bottom,
bottom of the 14th,
hit a walk off,
crushed a hanging curve ball out onto the fucking mass pike there and loved
Eckersley.
He was saying,
he was saying that Haley's going,
I love you.
I love it cause he just,
he just wants to go home.
It's fucking hilarious.
Um,
especially cause we have that 19 in a game with the Yankees a few days earlier.
But um,
oh Geez.
What the fuck was I talking about?
I literally just forgot everything I was talking about.
There was a point I was trying to make there on the arm then to the red sox
and then fucking out my year down my pant leg and I don't know where the fuck it
went.
I don't know what the fuck I was talking about there.
Oh,
I know.
I was talking shit,
well,
I didn't talk shit.
These fucking Blue Jay fans are giving me shit.
So out of nowhere,
this fucking drum company symbol making company that I'd never heard of before
called dream symbols.
I don't know where it starts talking Shit Gone Egg.
If,
if uh,
I figure I have to read it,
the Red Sox win and the Red Sox win,
we'll give you a free bag of symbols if the Blue Jays,
when uh,
you know,
you got to give us free advertising.
So the Red Sox win and you're like,
Eh,
fuck it.
What kind of symbols do you want to whether they,
if they were even serious,
I was just like,
you know,
get me a bag of fucking symbols.
I already have symbols.
I can't play the cymbals I have.
Why would I take a bag of yours that you could actually sell to someone who
knows how to play drums?
So just for the fuck of it,
I'm gonna,
you know,
but if I'm going to start the advertising with a free read,
I've never heard of these guys.
Dream symbols.
[inaudible] symbols.
You have a dream.
You can have some symbol of man have them in a bag,
man.
Uh,
though relatively new on the market.
Dream cymbals and gongs produced worldclass handmade produces worldclass
handmade symbols out of a factory and China's Wu Han region.
Am I going to be put on a watch list?
I didn't know you.
I thought we'd though those guys were the enemy,
which is crafted excellent gongs for generations,
for drummers searching for their own style.
Dream is a dream come true.
Each symbol has its own unique voice enhancing musicians distinct in this
dreams.
I actually listen to us.
A couple of people play the cymbals.
They sound pretty good,
you know,
and I would imagine because they're lesser known,
Aka nuts.
Siljan not Selgin,
not Sabian none fucking paste or pasty over the fuck you say it.
Meinl all the kids play meinl now.
Okay,
everybody's got to play the MEINL.
She wanted to be different.
Why don't you play dream symbols or don't?
I don't give a fuck.
They're not paying me.
You can buy a set of these symbols and roll them down the fucking hill for all.
I give a shit.
All right now into the real stuff.
All right.
That was just a warmup,
able to start doing that.
Free advertising.
Just a warmup.
I apologize if I'm making a lot of noise.
I've got a cough drop in fucking my boys.
Oh,
who is it?
look who's here.
Hey Sweetheart.
My daughter's walking.
She's already knocking on doors.
Guess who learned how to crawl?
She crawls like an inchworm.
Ah,
you don't care about your toys though,
do you?
I love this new shiny thing she does when she sees and she looks away.
What's up buddy?
You're going to hang out.
Watch another 14 things or red sox baseball with me tonight.
We actually already went.
Oh,
okay.
All right.
It's hot as hell in here.
Turn it on if you don't mind.
Okay,
bye.
Bye.
Hey Nia.
What would you do if somebody had that level of bad breath?
I'd read that thing to you.
Valid ptosis and literally had like that fucking slime along the gum line.
There's no way you're kissing them,
right?
It's too gross.
Would you say anything?
I honestly think
it depends on how much he likes her.
You know what I mean?
If you really,
really likes her,
like,
damn,
I could really see myself with this girl.
Then you say something.
How do you see past?
You know what all I could think of person.
All I could think of was when you know when they,
just the day when they just empty the dumpster and you look inside of it and all
that.
Fucking that liquid slime.
That's all I could.
Oh God,
no.
I feel like if someone is that poor with their dental hygiene,
I feel like that definitely is a red flag,
to be honest.
If it were me,
yeah,
you're not going downstairs.
You've seen the attic and I don't want to see the basement
right now.
I know.
She's so cute.
Okay.
All right.
Turning the AC.
You don't mind?
I'd bug me last night.
By the way.
You all impressed that I got to go to sleep.
It bugs me
every time you pull me back in.
Yes,
I know,
but I was trying to compliment you.
I know.
I thought you felt,
you know
I didn't know.
Yeah.
I didn't know I had difficulties getting her to go to sleep.
You were like,
I think at it.
Oh that just means I don't want to do it.
I can do it.
I just don't want to do it.
Oh
really?
Cause you made it seem like I like I,
you made me feel bad for you.
Like you felt like,
oh,
it's not like I do it everyday.
Like you do.
Like you felt somehow it bothered you inside?
No,
I just knew it was easier.
It was easier for you to do it.
Okay.
Cause you know,
you can always tap out.
It's like drunk drivers with Uber so you can always take your boob out and then
put her to sleep with that.
I can't do that.
Okay.
I'm a man without a country there.
Yeah.
I thought that meant that you felt like you didn't really have a place in terms
of like getting her to go to sleep,
but now I'm realizing that you're just lazy.
So
Lazy.
I worked all day in a writer's room staring at a computer screen,
trying to think of chokes for animated children.
Okay.
Um,
all right.
Just for that,
I'm drinking tonight and I'm going to be really belligerent,
extra belligerent tonight.
I know she's adorable.
And you know what?
Adorable is not funny.
So for the past five minutes,
you keep calling me back.
You see what she does?
She yells at me.
Could you put the AC on please,
sweetheart?
Yeah,
one more time.
I swear to God.
I'm going to try it.
All right.
Oh me,
I gotta read this one thing for you.
I read this one thing for you.
No,
I'm trying to leave.
Go put the AC on.
Don't doubt out.
Right.
You could have got me worse.
He could have got me worse.
Um,
all right.
Passionate women hit hard.
I don't know if you've ever noticed that you did some chicken,
which says no direction.
She bawls her fist up.
I mean,
you can literally just continue wheat and you club sandwich,
but if he gets a woman with passion that,
or if they had an older brother and it's going to fucking hurt a little bit.
All right.
Audibles doctor Katz.
Dr Katz,
is this the comedian?
Doctor Katz.
Jonathan Katz.
I used to open for this guy way back in the day when I started out.
He's fucking hilarious.
Genius,
Doctor Katz.
The audio files is the new comedy series.
Free now@audible.com doctor Katz to cold classic TV comedy is black is back.
Sorry,
that was a black company.
His back as a premium podcast with the original cast at audible.com/doctor Katz.
Ah,
Jesus Christ.
Jonathan,
if you listened to this,
I want to do an episode eaves dropped.com oh eavesdrop on top comics on couch
with Hollywood's favorite shrink therapists,
Silverman,
Ted Danson,
Ray Romano,
no
weird.
Al Yankovic,
Kristen Schaal,
Maria Bamford,
Paul F Tompkins.
That's how fuck,
look at that.
That's all a listers right there.
Some guy named Jon Hamm and somebody named
the fuck is that.
He said,
I got like half the copy.
It says some somebody named Moore.
Then that's it.
Comedians finally get the therapy they need and you get free antidepressants in
your ear on Doctor Katz,
the audio files exclusively now at audible.com/dr cats all that's awesome.
Oh,
look who's back.
Oh Shit.
Mototo beyond days me on days I been watching the fucking socks do,
do Dodo Ids be d nights?
And so I find my cock and my balls and my fucking tanked goes around in my ass.
I always say,
Hey Tao,
I fucked it up.
But who gives this ship?
Um,
fucking squat and non dream symbols and it doesn't hurt.
All right me undies.
Mondays are the softest,
most comfortable underwear you'll ever wear.
Period in summer is the perfect time to figure out how little your balls are
going to sweat while you upgrade your underwear drawer because everyone is
thinking about looking good and feeling good and be young.
These are the ultimate feel good undies.
Every pair of meundies is sustainably sourced and made from micro modal,
modal,
a fabric softer three times far softer than cotton because me undies Dotcom,
I got to get glasses man because me undies,
okay
come in all kinds of colors and patterns and they release new limited edition
patterns each month that always sell out.
This month's pattern
were designed by legendary 80s clothing,
brand,
cross colors with names that live up to their bold design and bright colors.
Increase dps should it be piece.
There's another one called you dig,
and that's what people,
itchy balls and the old g.
Oh,
Jesus.
Granddad with his balls hanging down.
There's,
what'd it be?
Spend x,
um,
to hold everything together.
You got to see him for yourself.
And right now you'll say 20% off your first pair and receive free shipping only
at [inaudible] dot com slash burn if you don't love your first pair of me
undies,
they're free.
You get 20% off your first pair plus free shipping at [inaudible] dot com slash
[inaudible] that's [inaudible] dot com slash [inaudible] [inaudible] dot com
slash bar
two more,
two more.
All right,
lift.
Lift man.
Um,
Lyft knows that their drivers are what?
Keep them moving so they do everything they can to make sure that drivers are
happy on every trip.
Lyft is the ride sharing company that believes in treating its people better.
Lift belly.
I love this shit.
I love this Hatfield and McCoy thing.
That's going on with them.
And that other company that rhymes with Uber.
Yeah.
When I read this copy,
what I learned from Lyft is that if you drive for that other company that rhymes
with Boober,
they evidently treat you like shit and you don't get tipped or something.
I don't know what the fuck happens,
but that they're totally good.
No.
Yeah.
This is the place.
This is the ride sharing app that gives a fuck about their drivers.
Luke does a ride sharing company that believes in treating it's people better
lift the leaves.
It being a ride.
Sharing drivers should be fun if you're having a good time.
So are the passengers.
Ah,
well yeah,
not if you're partying,
you know.
Look,
don't have too much fun up there buddy.
Okay.
My life's in your hands there.
Uh,
if you're choosing a ride sharing company to drive for,
go with a company that treats you better.
Like Lyft.
Lyft was the first to offer in APP tap tipping.
When you drive,
when you drive for Lyft,
you'll keep 100% of the tips.
Drivers had been paid over $200 million in tips since the feature was
introduced.
Lift as even taking the guesswork out of pickups.
The new amp device uses color coding to tell passengers.
Find the drivers.
You can earn hundreds of dollars a week plus tips.
Want to earn more money?
Well,
drive more.
It's never been easier to give you self.
Uh,
I'll drive more.
It's never been easier to give yourself a raise.
That's all you gotta do is work more.
Well,
that's kind of how every job works,
isn't it?
Unless she wants salary.
Uh,
it's a simple formula.
Happy drivers mean happy passengers.
Maybe that's why nine out of 10 Lyft rides get a perfect five star rating.
Go to lift.com/bird today and get your $500 new driver bonus.
That's lyft.com/burr lyft.com/bar
okay.
I don't know why I just thought this,
but I don't think hours is going to catch Mercedes.
I just don't.
I don't know what the fuck's going on over there.
I know this season is only halfway over,
but I dunno.
Both Ferrari's,
both fucking left front tire is both in the final five laps.
No,
it's like a bad fucking Sitcom.
I'm sorry.
With all the fucking mealy mouth on this podcast.
I'm trying not to do it on the mic.
It's just I got this halls in my mouth.
Okay.
Because my fucking voice is shot once again,
and I got all this act and to do so I'm taking a break,
a momentary hiatus from screaming my jokes on stage.
You know,
I just really need to do,
I need to break smarter jokes,
did all that got to do was just come out.
Same.
Wear a suit,
bing,
bang,
boom.
And I'm done.
All right.
Simply safe summer.
It's prime time for burglary.
Those fucking cops.
Why can't they do it in the winter when you're already miserable?
Yeah.
Having a good time.
I think.
I really think she's the one where if my furniture a summer is prime time for
burglary,
so now is the time to protect your home.
For a limited time.
You can take a whopping $100 off simply safe,
some special summer package that is simply safe's.
Biggest ever summer sale.
It has everything you need to protect your home and arsenal of security sensors
to secure each door and window.
You're simply safe.
System comes with a panic button,
a blaring extra siren and a wireless connection to authorities and police
dispatch.
Just don't leave it in your bed.
So when you roll over and you sleeping gonna wake up with three good cops with
that gun in your face.
Yeah,
I swear to God I live here.
Um,
okay.
Your family,
your home and everything in it.
Stay safe around the clock with simply safe.
There are no long term contracts,
no installation costs and no hidden fees and 24 seven professional monitoring.
It's just 1499 a month for a panic button.
How many seek Jodie foster played for paid for that fucking panic room.
Okay,
and what an idiot.
She had the whole room.
All you needed was a button.
Once you press that,
the attacker is going to be a golf fuck and he's going to leave you press the
button,
right?
Call to action,
get $100 off to summer security package.
It's simply safe.com/bar and I'll simply say [inaudible] dot com now the sale
ends July 31st that's simply safe bird.com to get $100 off simply safe.com
simply safe bar.com fuck.
All right,
I'm just going to swallow this fucking
okay.
Rather we go.
All right.
Sorry.
33 fucking minutes and me fucking sloshing around here at 37 38 minutes.
All right.
So anyways,
I'm going to be in New York,
sweat my balls off for the next fucking week.
Being the new Cynthia Nixon and uh,
you know what kills me is,
uh,
I,
I found out too late that guns and roses is going to be playing at the Apollo
theater that night.
The 30th anniversary,
30th anniversary of the,
um,
of appetite for destruction.
They're going to be doing it there.
I,
I fuckin have figured out a way to weasel my way into that show.
It's done through Sirius Xm.
God knows I'd done enough shit over there and I completely fucked myself cause I
didn't realize that show was going on.
And then I'm going to be in New York and while I'm in New York,
John fucking mayor with the night game opening up with Dave Lucha on drums at
the La Forum.
Steve Jordan on drums,
two of my favorite drummers of all fucking time to incredible fucking bands.
One of the best venues to see a god damn concert.
And I show up like a fucking day or two later and I missed that.
You know,
I just feel like I missed everything.
Um,
anyways,
that's a podcast.
Thank you guys so much for listening.
I hope you have a wonderful weekend.
You can't,
um,
yeah,
that's it.
Listen to this music is,
we uh,
transferred to another half hour of free shit
here from a Thursday afternoon podcast from a Thursday gun buy in a year.
That already happened or maybe it's early this year.
I don't know.
I don't choose them.
That's it.
I'll,
I'll talk to you on [inaudible]
Monday.
No phobia.
Hey Billy Bo Baggins is it gain or phobia you afraid of the gynecologist?
I am a 28 year old college guy.
Who has,
was it Jane or Phobia?
The fear of women.
I've never heard of this.
Uh,
he said when I was a kid,
I used to get the shit kicked out of me and girls would always spread rumors
about me and it would really screw with my mind.
Okay,
wait a minute.
You didn't get along with men or women.
Well,
what were you,
what were you doing?
You know what?
That's the last thing you needed to hear.
Well,
what's wrong with you?
I'm sorry.
Forgive me.
I'm not a trained professional,
so you know,
you're,
you're asking a more on and you know I'm going to behave accordingly.
Here we go.
As I grew up,
I started to resent and hate all the people around me that my mother tells me
about false rape accusations.
And that makes,
oh,
and that makes females look even more scarier than they already were.
See,
guys,
just kick the shit out of you.
Females psychologically fuck you up and don't even have a tint of remorse or
empathy.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
All right,
dude.
So your mother's is psycho and she put all these fears on you.
Yeah,
you got to,
maybe I would seek some professional help before you turn into Norman Bates.
Uh,
all right,
let's continue this then.
I hear about all the women raping men in the divorce courts and in general,
adding more fuel to the fear.
Dude.
Yo,
you're overthinking this shit.
I mean,
you probably heard half of that from me,
but I'm an idiot.
Don't listen to me.
He said,
it's gotten to the point where when a female introduces herself to me,
I just see her as a potential mind raping and prolonged exercise of getting
verbally abused.
So I just always say sorry,
but I have somewhere to be right now.
Goodbye.
And I walk away.
Sir,
can I steal that from you?
I want to use that next time they get pulled over.
Yeah.
License.
Reza.
Sorry,
Lynn.
I have somewhere to be right now.
Goodbye.
And you just,
just act like the rain man,
and they'll fucking leave you alone.
That's actually brilliant.
Uh,
he said they scare me so much,
but I'm still attracted to them.
Oh my God,
Dude.
You listen,
you gotta.
You gotta you gotta get past this.
Hopefully you're still young and this is early on,
but this is something where you are,
you know,
everybody is trying to go towards the,
uh,
we'll just call it a whatever planet live happily ever after.
But if you're off by just one degree,
you're not really going to notice when you're 22,
24,
you know,
but by the time you're 40,
you're going to be about a million miles off course.
So let's try to get you some help.
I would go see a therapist,
sir.
Um,
and I know I've been joking around,
but I kind of have to do that because this is a podcast.
But,
um,
well actually because it's a podcast that's supposed to be funny.
I'm not saying you can't have a series podcast.
Um,
yeah,
I would go get some help quickly and I would get rid of all those fears and I
would say a lot of the fears of probably uh,
put into your head by your mom when you were really young and you need to try
and get those out of there before they take any more route than they already do
already have once finish here.
He said,
my mind says,
stay the fuck away while my Dick says do it.
Do it.
Fucking do it.
Uh,
but in this climate of unrestrained female
hypo agency and he went to fight,
I mean the shit that makes women invade male spaces and makes them change
everything to suit them through.
Dude,
you're taking your fucking fear of women.
You're,
you're,
you're blowing by me.
Listen,
are you a great guy?
If you're a great guy,
there's a great woman out there for you and the,
and it's a beautiful thing.
They're not all like this.
What you're doing is you're taking the worst of the worst of females and you're
printing it with a broad brush.
All right?
Um,
AH,
Jesus Christ.
I'm relating
to this guy here.
He said I'd rather stay celibate for life.
All right.
Now I don't relate to that.
I am a loner to a vast degree,
but I got a loving family to back me up so I ain't on the fringe or anything.
I plan on just working towards my career and it did.
I write this like 20 years ago.
Jesus Christ plan on just working towards my career in education,
but either way I'll have to deal with women and it's been hard to do since
lately too.
So lately since my social skills tanked over the last nine months,
trauma,
Conga Line of horrific events happened and I am working on getting the
confidence back through Brazilian Jujitsu already lost 11 pounds and I'm
starting to feel a lot better.
All right,
well just don't go choke out any women.
All right.
I've tried to put them in the triangle.
He said any ways,
is there any way,
but martial arts are a great way to build self esteem from what I've heard
anyways.
Is there any,
is there any way to get rid of the insane fear I have about women or is it just
15 years of hurt that'll take almost forever an undue thanks and go fuck
yourself six ways from Sunday and good luck with your standup.
Um,
all right,
I'll see.
You were only 15.
Is that what you're saying?
All right dude.
First of all,
it's great you took up Brazilian Jujitsu,
he should know how to defend yourself and uh,
don't be a current about it when you become a black belt,
uh,
use it to save nerds and protect yourself but never be a bully.
Um,
and then as far as women,
I would actually try and talk to somebody about this and I would try to have
more of an open mind because right now if you only 15 years old or even if
you're young in your early twenties,
mid twenties,
you're basically,
you got the lottery pick as far as women goes.
All right.
They're all available.
Fall first round draft picks,
bunch of first round draft picks just sitting there
and you know,
depending on when you open your mouth and start talking to one is when you pick
in the draft if you don't want to meet sooner rather than later.
But I would just talk to somebody about
okay,
about,
about some of your issues.
Maybe it's school,
they got some free fucking therapy or something like that if you're too young to
pay for it.
But,
um,
I dunno,
I would talk to somebody,
I would talk to some of your guy friends about it.
I would,
you know what I would do,
I would openly talk about your fear of women to,
um,
to friends,
you know,
and I would,
I would sit down with your mother and just say,
listen,
I have major issues with women right now.
And I think some of it stems from a lot of the negative things that you've said
about them.
And I need you to stop doing that because it's,
it's fucking with me.
Don't,
don't say that part,
but say it in a nicer way.
Um,
but if she's,
you know,
I dunno,
that's the hardest fucking thing is because you are born into the religion of
your parents.
Okay.
Ain't no and into
all of their beliefs and hopefully they have more good than bad,
but they're human.
So they're going to be wrong.
And you know,
when you're a little toddler all the way through like seven,
eight years old,
your parents are God.
Like you just think they know everything and they have all the answers.
They never look unsure.
You do everything that they fucking say.
So a lot of that stuff just really takes deep root.
Like it's,
it's law in your head.
And then he,
the teenage years,
he started breaking away.
You realize some of his bullshit and let's win.
Some anger can come out and that type of stuff.
So I would say what you're going through is normal.
It's just that you maybe had an extreme,
uh,
helping of some fucking anti woman shit,
which I can relate to because I did too.
And I had to fight through that shit.
I mean,
it took me to get married.
Tell us 45 I had made you fucking issues.
But uh,
it's like anything look at,
just used the martial arts thing as a,
a metaphor or a simile,
whatever the fuck you're supposed to.
Whatever the right terminology is.
Look at you.
You did that.
You stuck with that.
You lost 11 pounds.
You work towards that.
Look at,
look at what you're,
you're getting,
you're getting positive results and it hasn't been easy,
right?
But You keep showing up.
You get positive results.
I would do the same thing with your women issues.
I would just start working on it.
Um,
you know,
next time a woman comes up and says hello,
don't say I have somewhere to go.
Just say hello back and stay in the conversation for as long as you can.
And when you feel like baling,
just say,
listen,
I'm really shy around women and it's something that I'm trying to work on.
Just put it out there.
And you know what I guarantee 80% of them are going to say,
ah,
you know,
when they do that,
they're going to love it.
And next thing you know you're out there watching a romantic comedy with some
lady having a good time.
But I would,
I would address it sooner than later.
I'm telling you,
dude,
it's you literally,
it's,
you think it's a mountain.
It's,
it's a fucking,
it's stepping up onto the curb.
It's all in your head.
And that's totally normal because I would guess that your fears started when you
were in your,
my mom's godlike phase of your life.
So you think,
you think it's,
ah,
okay.
What's that fucking mountain Everest that everybody tries to climb up.
It isn't.
Okay.
It's a little fucking ant hill and,
and you can do it.
All right.
I believe in you.
Good luck sir.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
hey,
what's going on?
It's Belper and it is the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
July.
Fucking something.
I don't know what it is cause it's Sunday.
It's going to be the 20th right
now.
Wait a minute.
I'm on September here.
God dammit
it is the 20th what are the fucking odds?
Are there any ways what's going on?
It's a billboard,
the Monday morning podcasts for a Monday,
July the 20th,
and I'm actually doing it Sunday night.
Cause whenever you're listening to this fucking thing,
um,
I'm probably out golfing.
Yes.
Believe in a,
not a guy who already has too many God damn hobbies with his pathetic drumming
and guitar playing.
Um,
I have,
I dunno,
I've somehow got sucked into that game,
fighting it,
fighting it my entire adult life.
All my friends,
not all my friends,
it's a bunch of fucking people I know.
They day,
day golf and uh,
I always viewed it like drinking coffee.
I just didn't like,
I don't know,
it just didn't look like that much fun,
but everyone was completely addicted to it.
You know,
I took a sip of fucking,
uh,
coffee when I was like eight years old and it tasted like shit.
Tasted like dirty water and it looked like dirty water and that's what it tasted
like.
And I never,
I never got into it.
And Dan and all my whole adult life,
I just watch all these people walking around.
They can't start their fucking day unless they get a cup of this shit.
You know,
all these people talking about people on crystal meth and addicted to alcohol
and shit like that.
I mean,
I guess they're not fucking slurring their speech,
you know,
it doesn't cause them to slap the fucking wife around or something like that.
So I guess it's kind of harmless.
But I dunno.
I remember this kid when I worked in a warehouse,
he used to drink like fucking eight cokes a day,
you know,
we'd like sucked down like one an hour when we were working and one day decided
to try to quit cold Turkey and this kid couldn't even function.
He had like this migraine headache.
He lasted like an hour and a half,
maybe two hours for up until our first break.
And he just finally,
he drank a coke and he just felt better.
So,
uh,
yeah.
So I avoided that shit.
And um,
I don't know.
I've been kind of worried about losing my memory and somebody told me if you
actually drink caffeine,
that actually helps with Alzheimer's.
I had an Italian meal a few weeks ago and I drank a shot of espresso or espresso
ever the fuck you say it.
And uh,
I dunno,
I have to,
I know,
I know.
It was fucking brutal.
I got it over with though.
And then someone was like,
no,
no.
I actually read where it adds to all Simer,
uh,
Alzheimer's disease.
And I was like,
you know what?
I don't give a fuck.
You know,
none of you are doctors who are giving me this advice,
you know,
it's fucking ridiculous.
He might not like,
how many times do you get done that?
You know,
you just sitting in a bar and somebody just says that we'll actually,
caffeine helps,
uh,
helps against a,
helps prevent Alzheimer's.
Eh,
they'd done studies.
Oh,
really?
Really?
Do you have any of those studies in front of you?
What?
What the fuck do you do?
Huh?
What do you,
what do you what,
what do you,
what does anybody do any more?
Huh?
What do you do?
Why don't you sit in a fucking cubicle looking at spreadsheets of the sweatshop
labor.
This is how fucked up this country is right now as far as like,
I'm really just trying to buy American made shit.
Um,
I actually went and I got a couch and I went to this,
uh,
this furniture store over here in the valley and it was uh,
you know,
allegedly American made shit.
So I,
I ordered this couch cause you know,
you don't want to take the one that's on the floor that everybody's fucking
plopped down on.
So I get this couch,
right.
So I'm like,
when I asked before I bought the couch,
you know,
cause I want to buy American made shit made by Americans.
You know what I mean?
Get this fucking country going again.
Well like we can't make a couch,
you know,
we've made the best looking fucking cars of all God damn time before we started
being cheap motherfuckers about it.
All right,
we went to the moon and we fake going to the moon.
I don't know what the fuck we did.
Okay.
But it was,
it was impressive.
We can make a goddamn couch.
Okay.
So I asked the guy,
where's the couch made?
He says it's made in Pasadena.
Long story short is I have a problem and I'm having a problem with the
upholstery that they put on the fucking thing.
So that was when I actually had to send the stupid couch back.
I actually learned of their process.
This is what they do.
They do make the couch in Pasadena,
they build the damn thing.
But when they put the upholstery on it,
they actually,
that part of the job,
they shipped it down to like Honduras.
Okay.
Think about that.
They build it.
And Pasadena,
I live over here in la.
All right.
And they fucking ship it to Honduras to,
to,
to have the uh,
the,
uh,
what did the upholstery put on it?
And then they ship it back to America.
So my thing is like how fucking cheap is the Goddamn labor down there that
that's,
that that's financially a better way to go.
You know
the fuck am I am talking about golf here.
I'm talking about fucking ship and couches to a hundred Doris.
I Dunno,
it's late at night here and I'm trying not to fucking scream and yell cause uh,
cause my neighbor is asleep in here.
Um,
yeah.
So anyways,
so I've,
uh,
taken up golf and a,
I still refuse to take it seriously.
Although I did go out and buy a little tiger woods outfit,
you know,
I dunno.
I just didn't want to go down there looking like a dose,
you know,
like the frat boy.
I figured if I dress nicely,
even if I suck,
maybe I look like,
you know,
I'm having a bad day or something.
So,
uh,
anyways,
I'm golfing right now.
That's what the fuck I'm doing.
And uh,
I missed that.
Oh,
a British show up.
And yesterday we're a Tom Watson,
Tom Watson.
I thought the guy was like dead,
you know,
even though our in Palmer is still alive,
this fucking guy,
he's like 59 years old.
He almost won the British open,
but then he didn't,
which is typical a golf,
oh my God,
something's great.
Great's going to happen and then it doesn't,
and then you watch somebody choke in front of their entire family.
I still haven't gotten over the math master's,
you know,
even though,
uh,
with Kenny Perry said his name,
he's one another.
Uh,
he wants to,
I don't know what the fuck he won,
but he didn't get a green jacket.
I can tell you that.
He can fucking tell you that.
What am I talking about this week?
Hey,
this is the deal.
All right.
And you know,
it's a deal cause I started the sentence off with,
hey,
I was trying to get your attention there.
Uh,
I'm going to be at the,
uh,
the comedy works in Denver,
Colorado on a Thursday,
Friday and Saturday of this week.
It's one of my favorite clubs out there.
And I also want to thank everybody who came out to see my show.
Um,
a week ago,
um,
at the punchline,
my had a great time as a first time I was onstage headlining since,
uh,
the middle of May because I was being a little fancy fucking dude.
There's,
Jimmy Norton says make it a movie or sitting around waiting to do my 11 lines,
however the fuck you want to look at it.
But I'm going to say it in the positive way.
I was making a movie and a,
I was a little,
a little rusty,
kind of found my,
I was a little little,
uh,
it's a little messy but uh,
I got through it but I always buy the second show is back on my game.
So I'm really looking forward to this and if uh,
you guys haven't been to listen to my podcast,
um,
I am going to be doing another special and it looks like it's going to be in
December and it looks like if everything works out,
I'm going to be taping it in San Francisco.
So,
um,
I am going to be in a theater or a comedy club near you from here till then,
from right now until then that I say that correctly.
Um,
I kind of have a bit of a,
it starts getting going basically right at the end of August and I'm just
hardcore September,
October,
November and half of December.
And then I'm going to tape the thing.
I am going to be hardcore on the road like the old days when I wasn't making any
money.
So I had to go out like three,
four times a fucking month and then do a bunch of spots in the city.
I'm going to be doing it like that.
And uh,
I'm looking forward to it.
I'm going to try to eat healthy on the road.
These are my goals.
Now.
Am I going to do it?
Who?
To?
Who the fuck knows?
All right.
I'm going to try not to drink when I'm on the road.
We can try to do some yoga.
I'm going to try to fucking do some cardio,
do some pull ups,
get myself in shape physically and uh,
not look like a bloated jackass.
That's the last thing you want to fucking do.
You don't want to sweat and you want to look like a bloated jackass during your
special.
And,
and then thirdly,
you want to be fucking hilarious,
but that,
that is the,
uh,
that is the order.
Number one,
you do not want to sweat we your balls.
It's no big deal.
They'll throw some laughter in there.
Maybe they'll sweeten it up or maybe they'll just play it once and people forget
about it.
But if you're pouring fucking sweat people,
people remember that Shit,
you know,
now why would you no,
you don't fucking do,
you don't do stand up.
All right,
I'm a little out of it here.
Uh,
all right,
what do we got here?
Um,
let's get on with the questions here.
Oh,
and if you knew to my podcast,
welcome,
uh,
my joke every week that I only have like 14 listeners,
but I got to admit,
I was at the,
uh,
when I was at the punchline on Monday,
punchline is San Francisco.
Somebody,
uh,
somebody yelled out Pau Gasol cause he wanted to see my impression as I was
talking about,
I did one here on the podcast.
So before I just launched into what I asked the people in the crowd,
hey,
how many guys listen to my podcast?
And it was literally like three quarters of the crowds.
So I was kind of blown away by that.
So I think I might be up to about 27 listeners,
their people.
Um,
anyways,
so,
uh,
let's get on with the podcast here.
Uh,
last week I was talking about all the celebrities who died.
And,
uh,
and how all these morons,
when Ed Mcmahon died and then Farah died and then,
uh,
Michael Jackson died.
People,
what do they say?
Oh,
there you go.
You know,
bad things coming.
Trees,
you know,
you fucking common trees and then Billy Mays dies,
right?
And then fucking,
uh,
what's his face fucking died earlier that month,
jerking off he dies,
right?
So that's five.
So you know what some fucking jackass sends me this email.
He was half joking around.
He goes,
you know,
he goes,
I'm one of those guys who actually says all the time that bad things come in
threes.
And I actually put up on my Facebook when those three celebrities dies,
when they died.
I wrote bad things come in three.
But then he mentioned that Karl Malden died.
He goes,
so technically that six,
so that's three and three.
So I am right.
Really?
That why isn't,
why isn't it bad things come and six you people are right with the bad things
coming through you guys.
You're out of your fucking minds.
Bad things come in threes.
So then what if somebody else dies and it goes up to seven,
then you keep your fucking mouth shut until two more people die and you got to
see you there.
There you go.
It comes back around again.
So you guys just basically,
you basically open your mouth when whatever bad shit has been happening is
divisible by three to prove your fucking point.
You know,
I could say bad things come in eight and just wait for the eighth bad to fucking
happen and then rattle them off.
They don't come in threes.
Bad things just continue to fucking happen,
which is why they have ice cream and alcohol,
you know,
so you can do fun shit while you're waiting for the neck.
The next bad thing to happen.
You know we had a heat wave out here there.
That's seven bad fucking things.
How will you will you will fucking old lady.
What kind of a fucking human,
what kind of a man says that shit.
I'm all right,
let's move on to some other stuff.
I know that guy,
I was just joking.
The guy was sent me the email and six,
but you know,
if I don't take it seriously,
then I don't get emotional about it.
And then the podcast isn't funny.
All right.
And then I lose a listener like that one woman from a fucking couple months ago,
I never heard from her again or her alleged friends who were listening.
So anyways,
uh,
which really affected the overall value of this podcast because I'm actually
doing this to get to a certain number and then I'm going to go corporate and
then I'm going to sell it just like these fucking cunts who start the myspace,
these,
the social,
uh,
social networks,
whatever the fuck you call them.
What they really are is they're basically clubs on the Internet.
You know,
like,
I've never believed in or not,
I was never into the club scene.
I know it's hard to believe that I didn't put on Cologne and go,
all right.
Maybe I did it a couple of times,
but I failed so horrifically.
And I've always said,
one of my strengths in life is I've known what I sucked at.
Okay.
And going to the night at the Roxbury things is,
uh,
not something I was never good at.
Skews me.
I need to drink here.
Okay.
All right.
That's gross.
You don't want to hear anybody chewing gum.
I fucking take a sip of anything,
but you know what?
It's hot as fuck out here.
I was playing drums all day.
I was actually playing with other human beings,
if you can believe it.
It's a whole different kind of drumming.
Um,
you know,
when you played by yourself and you do whatever the fuck you want and you screw
up,
there's nobody looking over their shoulder.
Like really?
You said you could play drums there.
There's nobody looking at you like that.
So it was a whole different fucking level.
Um,
anyways,
I wasn't no sound,
but the social networks say they're,
they're like clubs.
You know what I mean?
Where you got the new hot club and all the cool kids are going there and then
all the nerds show up and the bridge and tunnel crowd and all that shit.
And then everybody took off to Facebook.
That's what the fuck happened.
And then all the nerds went over there and then all the cool kids went over to
Twitter and now all the nerds have fallen.
I'm over there and it just,
it's going to be never fucking ending.
So,
uh,
that's why I'm still here on my space.
I like it.
It's a quiet bar now.
You know,
they can put the game on.
I could sit here,
sip on my drink,
having a good fucking time.
Dot.
All these crazy kids,
you know,
it's like a dive.
That's why I like my space.
It's like a dive bar right now,
you know?
No.
Okay.
Maybe it isn't.
Maybe I'm just a fucking loser.
It really is just a vast wasteland here.
I'm living a lie to you.
I just,
it's just whores and musicians.
That's all that's left here.
Um,
and one lonely comedian.
All right,
let's get to some feedback here.
This is from a woman,
um,
from a couple of weeks,
weeks ago when I was trashing that Carrie Underwood's song.
She said,
I am a woman and I've recently become a regular listener to your podcast.
I was listening to your July 6th podcast and laughed uncontrollably.
I actually liked,
I actually liked that Carrie Underwood's song and cannot argue with the things
you said.
The two piece combination to the cabbage comment was fricking hilarious.
Just thought you should hear it from a woman.
That was awesome.
All right,
well you know what h well we could thank you very much.
I appreciate that.
And just because you brought that up,
I'm going to actually give you the history behind the two piece combination to
the cabbage actually where I heard that and was actually a sleigh.
I gave a variation of it.
I was on my way to do a standup Gig in one of the outer boroughs in New York.
Um,
and I was with somebody and they were pissed at somebody else and they were
saying how they were going to kill him and they were not joking and they were
going off and just like,
you know this motherfucker,
this is my fucking dad.
I'm going to fuck on bookbub.
Abolish Shit.
And he was basically,
and I'm looking at the Duke because he really,
you know,
some people just say,
I'm going to fucking kill this guy.
This guy was dead serious.
So it was kind of an awkward moment know I'm just sort of like nod and you know,
trying to act like I hear somebody everyday tell me that they're going to kill
another human being.
And uh,
he was talking about he was gonna shoot him in the head and he,
the way he put it,
he's
now granted I hadn't left up to this point.
He said he was gonna shoot him in the head.
And then there was this awkward silence and then he just says a throw of late
throwaway line.
He just,
he said two beans to the cabbage and it was like a half second pause.
And I just started roaring laughing,
which got him laughing and then we were just fucking laughing.
And then he kept trying to say,
no,
I'm serious son as he's fucking laughing.
And it was just one of those great fucking moments and nobody ended up getting
killed at the end of it.
And it was just something that's just stuck.
It's not the beans,
it's the cabbage.
There's just something,
there's something about when you do damage to somebody's head that it literally,
cabbage is the,
I don't know why it's just perfect.
It's just perfect.
So,
uh,
that's how I got to cabbage reference.
And uh,
of course everyone was remade.
I didn't even tell you the borough.
See right there.
That's how you do it for the fuck am my kid.
And if anything ever happened and they dragged me and they wouldn't have to do
good cop,
bad cop,
all they'd have to do is slam the door.
And I'd be like,
okay,
we were driving.
Oh,
the [inaudible] and anyways,
sorry,
here's a fucked up new story for you.
Ah,
Shit.
God Damn.
Pizza Shit computer.
Um,
or maybe it's the person operating it.
All right,
here we go.
He's a fucked up new story that somebody sent me.
A lacrosse woman.
Now this is not a woman who plays Lacrosse.
It's a woman from a town evidently called Lacrosse.
And this story is so fucked up that I actually researched it on the internet.
And by research,
I mean I did a quick search and I clicked on the first story and it agreed with
me and therefore it became fact.
So with that background,
let's read the story.
All right.
I lacrosse woman,
a woman from Lacrosse,
uh,
is accused of stabbing her boyfriend Tuesday after she caught him watching
pornography and masturbating according to Lacrosse police reports.
Okay.
She caught him watching pornography and masturbating.
So she allegedly stabbed him.
Uh,
Rachel Ferrara,
23,
founder of 24 year old boyfriend inside her home.
Um,
the couple argued and four are accused the man of explicative being a,
an an explicative cheat or being a fucking cheater because evidently he was
masturbating to pornography.
Uh,
she evidently punched him twice in the abdomen,
kicked him in the groin a four hour,
then back the man into the kitchen,
which I know a lot of people like that.
And they,
oh,
a woman couldn't back a man and the,
yes she can because we can not lay a hand on you.
So when you go psycho,
that's what you do.
You back into the room going,
honey,
relax,
relax.
Crazy.
He take a couple of more,
you know,
put you,
you try to do the George for me.
You know,
George Foreman covers up his body.
Layton is a query.
You got one forum soda in front of your face and the other one below you.
It's almost like you're starting to cross your arms to do that run DMC thing,
but you stopped midway,
you know,
like the end of chips.
Um,
anyways,
God bless you if he got that joke.
All right.
Uh,
so for hour then back,
the man is the kitchen.
She grabbed a five inch serrated knife and slashes arms before stabbing him in
the abdomen.
According to reports,
uh,
she reportedly refused as attempts to calm down,
calm her down,
and she screamed at him to leave.
The man drove himself to Gunderson,
a blood or a medical center where he was treated and release.
Uh,
the woman Ferrara was arrested on charges of disorderly conduct while armed and
recklessly endangering safety.
She's expected later today in Lacrosse County Circuit Court.
So the man who sent me this said really disorderly conduct while armed and
recklessly endangering safety.
If I as a guy went and stabbed my girlfriend and the abdomen because she had a
vibrator in her Twat,
I would get charged with attempted murder and possibly rape.
But I guess that's why we make a dollar more an hour.
Oh Shit.
Did I just steal one of your jokes?
Oh,
well sincerely.
And then he names the name of a comedian who's known for stealing jokes.
Um,
yeah,
that is a kind of a light charge.
Wouldn't you say?
You know,
I'm not sitting here saying that she actually did any of this shit because I
understand that when I know what alleged means.
Okay.
But my thing is what a,
you know,
if she did do this shit,
which they're trying to,
uh,
prove disorderly conduct,
well armed and recklessly endangering safety.
Now what does that mean to you guys?
Okay.
If I told you I was arrested of disorderly conduct while armed and recklessly
endangering safety,
you know what that would mean.
That would mean I'm at a gun range and I'm shit faced and I didn't properly
holster my,
my weapon after I shot at a paper target.
That's kind of what it seems like,
you know,
or maybe I'm doing something,
I'm trying to shoot a bottle rocket out of my asshole or I dunno.
I Dunno what,
you know what I mean?
But that we would,
you know,
if I told you I got arrested for that Shit,
you wouldn't thought that I fucking stab somebody,
you know,
slash their arms and then fucking stabbed him.
You know,
I don't understand.
When is the world going to understand that whoever is wielding a knife,
if they stab somebody,
you know,
regardless of their sex that is attempted murder,
isn't it?
That's fucking unreal.
I got to tell you something.
Uh,
I'm going to go see that movie coming out.
I think it's called orphan.
I don't know what with that little scary girl in it where they,
they,
they uh,
they rescue this girl like some fucking psycho pit bull,
like the one that I have.
Um,
oh my God,
she had a fucking dream the other night and fuck you,
you dude from England.
All right.
You fast forward through this shit.
I don't give a fuck do from a couple of weeks ago.
He says he can't stand my stories about it.
I'm going to fucking tell when every week just to annoy you.
This is how crazy shelter dogs are.
My fucking dog is laying there and I'm about,
and I'm like,
you know,
drifting off to sleep and all of a sudden I'm hearing like
or
right.
And it's like seeping into my dream.
I,
you know,
I'm fucking,
I don't know,
talking to some whore in my dream and all of a sudden she turns into like a bear
or some shit,
right?
So I fucking wake up.
I'm like fuck.
And the dream is,
then I'd look over and there's my damn Doug sound asleep moving.
One of his paws gone
doing that shit.
So I dunno what the fuck to do,
right?
You know,
you're not supposed to wake a sleeping,
sleep walk and human being.
What do I do with the fucking psycho pitbull that's evidently having words with
somebody in a goddamn dream.
So I decided to wake her up.
I was like,
Cleo,
cleo.
And then she immediately just sort of woke up and then looked at me and just
started wagging her tail.
Like,
oh,
hey,
how's it going?
And then just put her head back down again.
Like all that shit just didn't happen.
It's just fucking
the fucking things.
Nuts.
All right,
let's get back to the,
uh,
let's get back to,
I want to see that movie,
that movie a orphan there.
Um,
which is,
uh,
you know,
I was just,
there's something about women when they're the bad guy.
It,
I,
it's extra scary to me.
You know what I'm talking about,
a guy being a maniac.
I know.
You just look at it.
They had fuck that guy.
Fuck him.
I,
you know,
whatever.
I'd drop,
kick them.
You know,
you just think shit like that for the most part.
But there's something about,
I dunno if it's,
they've always freaked me out and for some reason,
you know,
I was thinking about that.
How like women,
you know,
women be in the,
uh,
the Michael Myers to me is way more scary than the guy.
Um,
and I remember when I wave back in like 82 or 83 when I first got cable,
um,
I was watching late night and I can't even,
you know,
I really feel bad for people of this generation who have just grown up with
cable.
You have no idea how fucking insane cable is.
You have no idea.
We had three networks to uhs and that was it.
And nobody cursed,
no titties,
no nothing.
It was,
it was unbelievable.
Unbelievable when that shit came out.
So anyways,
so I'm watching late night and I was watching this movie and I looked it up on
youtube.
It's actually the movie is called curtains and uh,
it has one of the most bizarre fucked up scenes.
You know,
I went back and I watched it.
It really didn't hold up over time.
Um,
but back in the day it really fucking freaked me out.
it basically,
there's a scene in that movie curtains where there's a girl who's out on a pond
and she's fucking take,
I can't even explain it for,
I forget,
cause I haven't seen the movie in so long.
The clip I watched,
she's basically uncovering snow and you think it's a dead body,
but it's a doll underneath.
And then she's holding it up.
The doll has a weird look on her face and then there's sort of cutting to these
fucking ice skates slowly in slow motion,
just beginning to skate across the pond towards this girl.
And of course she has no idea that this fucking thing is coming towards her and
they just show it from a distance and it just looks like a person.
And as it gets closer and closer,
it just,
it's this fucking psycho.
I think it's a woman,
I can't even remember,
but it looks like a woman's got a female face,
like a which face with long hair and she skating like she speed skate and then
she pulls out like this fucking sickle.
I can't exceed.
It's fucked up,
right?
I mean,
I don't know dude.
I went from Barney Miller to that.
That was,
that's what it was like to have no cable and then to have that,
and I'm like literally 12,
13 fucking years old.
The movie's called curtains.
Just look it up.
Um,
it's the only part of the movie probably worth Worth Watch.
And you can actually watch the clip.
And when you're a,
when you're there,
there's another clip that you have to watch that kind of ties into this whole
thing where a women,
you know,
when they do violence shit,
they just don't get charged with the same stuff that a guy does.
And if you really feel that there's no justice in the world ever when it comes
to females physically doing stuff to guys,
I have a video for you and I cannot take credit for this youtube video.
Um,
this isn't even youtube video of the week.
It's not youtube video of the month as far as I'm concerned.
This is youtube video of the fucking year.
This is what I want you guys to Google right here.
Go whatever.
Go on Youtube and search.
Tough talk and college girl.
All right,
somebody sent me this clip.
It is unbelievable.
Okay.
And toughest spelled t u.
F.
Okay.
And it basically in result balls,
the classic scenario,
the hot chick in the bikini,
there's some guy hitting on her.
She uh,
starts giving him shit back.
He gives her shit and then she throws a drink in his face,
you know,
and then turns around and walks away because that's what you do when you throw a
fucking drink in somebody's face.
You just walk away.
You know?
Now as a guy,
I feel bad for guys of whoever's fucking listen to this right now and you're not
near a fucking computer cause you really just need to watch it.
You really need to watch it because in a perfect world this is what you'd be
able to do as a guy.
All right,
now I don't,
I have to talk about this video.
I,
you know,
spoiler alert,
I'm going to tell you what the fuck happened.
So if you want to hit pause and fucking watched a video or if you want to listen
to me talk about the video,
this is,
I'm battling right now to give you that opportunity.
Okay?
Cause I'm going to ruin what the fuck happens.
Okay,
I'm going to talk about it in three,
two,
one.
All right,
here we go.
So she throws the fucking drink in his face and just turns around and walks
away.
Okay.
Cause that's what happens in movies.
Nothing ever happens.
And not to mention,
if you ever do go to make a move on some girl who does some shit like that to
these,
usually a couple of bounces there to choke you out.
Basically the scenarios that are outside of the pool,
you know,
I can't defend the kid who got the drink thrown in his face.
He definitely kind of looks like a,
he could be a bit of a Douche,
but whatever.
He's got the balls to walk up to this hot chick that back in the day when I was
his,
I wouldn't have the balls to walk up to.
So I give the kid props.
Okay.
But he does have his sunglasses dangling from his ears and hanging underneath
his chin.
So right there,
the Douche level of that guy's pretty fucking high,
so whatever.
So she throws the fucking drink in his face and just walks away.
You know,
she doesn't give a shit that he's got to go home and change or he's got to stand
there and be sticky in 80 degree weather outside the fucking the pool.
So he immediately,
you know,
it takes a half a pause and then just fucking walks up to the girl and she's
still trying to act tough.
She's like,
what?
You know you like when white girls,
because they've watched reality TV now know how to act ghetto.
She's like what?
And throws the empty plastic cup down on the ground.
Like she's going to do something.
All right.
And the dude,
I thought he was going to wind up and blast or in the face.
So at this point I'm watching it with one eye cause I don't give a fuck what a
girl does.
You never want to see or get his fucking closed fist did.
It's,
it's just,
it's ugly even though she threw the drink.
But the dude
fucking just,
I had to watch it twice to see what he does.
He does a fucking leg sweep that,
that I swear to God,
he could've beat one of the Gracies with one of this.
He just,
it's like the girl standing up and then she is not,
he just went,
I can't believe like from her knees down,
both those parts of her legs didn't fly off like a mortar hit him.
That's how fucking he just fucking,
I'm like literally standing up acting it out again.
Huh?
This is like when I told the Rosebowl story back in the day,
right.
He literally just fucking leg sweeps her and she just calls down to the ground
and she hits the back of her head and the concrete and that's the part where
you're like,
Ooh,
not good.
Funny until the back of the head hits the concrete.
But she immediately goes like,
oh,
screaming basically sounding the alarm for all the guys to come and rescuer,
which they kind of don't,
they kind of all stand up like,
hey dude,
whoa,
what's going on?
You know,
and uh,
and I,
you know,
why did I try to describe it?
I can't do justice.
You have to see this tough talk in college girl,
just Google and spelled tough.
T U F F and I swear to God,
like I said,
I don't advocate hitting a woman.
And I think women should respect that rather than take advantage of it.
And I really think if you take a full drink and you throw it in somebody's face,
you're really taking advantage of that.
A man should never hit a woman.
Okay.
And uh,
I really have to be honest with you.
If the guy punched her in the face,
I would have said he was a Douche.
But there's something about a leg sweep that it had a,
uh,
a gentleman quality to it.
You know,
in fact,
that's the comment I left under the first time the video is update was taken
down.
But the comment I left was leg sweep equals gentlemen,
I gotta be honest with you.
I've seen girls get punched.
I've seen them get slapped.
Okay.
I've seen a Guy Shaker girl,
I've seen a dude,
choker girl,
none of this I advocate,
but I've seen all that.
I have never seen somebody go for the leg sweep.
And it was,
it was,
uh,
it was surprising.
You know what I mean?
It's like when you see a movie and you think you know how it's going to end,
like oh Jesus.
And then the hero comes in and the white horse and then no,
no,
Leonardo Dicaprio gets popped in the fucking elevator and you're like,
Holy Shit.
Holy Shit,
I didn't see that comment.
That's what,
that's what that fucking leg sweep was like.
It was like seeing DiCaprio get popped in the departed fucking phenomenal
youtube video of the year.
Why don't we have that?
That's a new segment here on,
uh,
my Monday morning podcast.
Let's,
let's have nominees.
Okay.
Cause when they nominate the Oscars,
it's usually like two,
three months ahead of time.
That's what we'll have in December.
You guys just remind me,
we will have the nominees for youtube video of the year for me.
Okay.
Uh,
that movie is like the equivalent to that.
I'm not gonna say there will be blood.
It's more like no country for old men and all that kid should just hang up,
bowl cut and just not blinked when he fucking did it.
And,
and that,
that I would have bought it on DVD.
Um,
all right.
So there you go.
Okay.
Was that misogynistic enough?
We always have to have that moment in this fucking podcast.
All right,
let's wind it down here with the questions cause it's getting late.
And uh,
I gotta get up early here because I have a tee time.
[inaudible] stepped on the ball.
All right.
Questions.
Um,
hey Mr. Byrd,
how's that for making you feel?
Fucking old.
It did,
it did make me feel it.
All right.
Um,
I was just wondering what your thoughts on we're on,
why people are so easily offended,
especially by foul language.
I thought you might have some insight here as someone who uses the word cunt and
fuck quite regularly.
Um,
hey,
guilty as charged.
Um,
maybe,
um,
it has something to do with the fact that I live in the south,
but it seems like you dropped the f bomb here.
Oh,
I see what you're saying.
Maybe it has to do with the fact that I live in the south,
that if you drop the f bomb here or tell someone,
um,
okay.
Tell someone with all,
all the fucking padding.
Oh,
I didn't,
I enlarge this.
I am the worst reader.
I'm sorry guys.
Let me start this again.
Uh,
maybe it's something to do with the fact that I live in the south,
but it seems like if you dropped the f bomb here or tell,
tell something to someone without all the fucking padding and they just lose
their shit.
Um,
do you think this has something to do with the pussification of America or do
most people just grow up in a household where ball busting?
Oh,
do most people not grow up in a household where a ball busting is commonplace?
Um,
I dunno,
you know,
when I go across America,
I don't see a lot of pussies.
I see a lot of psychos.
I just think in general that,
um,
this country has,
you know,
just really the become corporate and they cast a wide net.
They're always commercial fishing,
so they're trying not to offend people.
So a lot of the shows on TV have sort of been a dumbed down I think,
but in general,
I mean,
I live in America and I say fucking cunt all the time as do all of my friends.
And uh,
there you go.
So I'm defining America by how I behave.
Um,
I dunno.
I think,
I think certain people grow up,
uh,
with ball busting and other people don't.
And the reality is everybody has a different line.
And I think the real thing is that people who get offended are way more
organized.
Um,
and they complain and they write letters and people who don't give a fuck,
don't give a fuck enough to write a letter to say,
I don't give a fuck.
You know,
so there you go.
Did you guys hear that Burp?
That was one of those internal burps that I heard in my head and I can't tell if
that was out loud.
All right.
Um,
all right,
let's move on to the next one.
Um,
hey bill,
big fan love you.
Coon muddy and you put kids to fucking hilarious.
Thank you very much.
Uh,
I appreciate that.
You do it for free.
Thank you.
Anyways,
I have a question for you.
When a comedian such as yourself recorded a CD or a DVD,
is that a onetime shot or are you able to reshoot if you are unhappy with the
show?
Um,
it all depends.
I like in for the most part,
yeah,
if you do like a standup special,
you do a,
you do at least two shows.
I was watching a guy recently on HBO hype and his special and he was talking
about working somewhere in Texas and he was going to do four shows and from the
four shows he was going to put together the special,
but for the most part you do at least two.
So this is how it's worked with me.
I did a CD called emotionally unavailable,
which is available on iTunes.
Um,
I really need a whore out my shit more too,
by the way.
Um,
but how I did that was,
I taped that at the last house in Philadelphia and I was doing four shows to
Friday and two Saturday and I taped all the shows.
I listen back to all the shows and I just liked the second show Saturday night
and I liked it and I got heckled and there was some awkward moments in it and it
just sounded like a show.
And what I liked about the old school comedy albums that I used to listen to
when I was growing up as you really felt like,
um,
you were kind of in the nightclub when you were listening and that type of
thing.
And it just,
I don't know,
with all this protools stuff,
you can really make something sound really slick.
And I,
you know,
I think I wrote that in the liner notes.
Wow.
I'm really going back a long way.
I think the liner notes I actually wrote,
like,
I didn't kind of want to splice together a performance that never really
happened,
you know?
So,
uh,
and then the other half was I was fucking lazy and it was true.
I wasn't going to go through four hours of fucking audio and just listening to
me do the same.
I just couldn't fucking do it.
So I was like,
you know what?
I liked that second show Saturday.
So that's how I did that.
That one on the Hbo one,
when I did my half hour,
there was a two tapings and my first show went really well.
So I knew I had a good special.
And then I came out the second one and the second one I was even more loose and
that one just went ridiculously great.
And afterwards the director was like,
you know what?
I think that second one was the one other than this one little joke.
So why don't we just take one little joke from the first one,
stick that in and the rest will be the second show.
And I said,
works for me.
So that's how that one went together.
And why do I do this was only one show.
Um,
that one.
And that was because of the budget.
Uh,
we kind of waited a little too long to get a theater and we had to spend more
money than we thought.
And then in the end we only had the budget to do one of them.
So,
um,
what you see is what you get on that one.
That was just one,
one take.
And I left out some tags and that type of shit.
And it was kind of freaking me out in the beginning of the special.
Um,
if you look closely in my eyes,
you'll see it a couple of times.
Um,
but then I was just like,
well fuck it.
No one's going to know that I missed the tags,
you know,
this is the special bill.
Why don't you get present and fucking deliver it?
So I just,
you know,
um,
yeah,
that's how I did that one.
But,
um,
yeah,
basically speaking,
you don't just do one unless you have no fucking budget.
Are you fucked up your budget or something like that.
So this one that I do and uh,
San Diego,
San Diego and San Francisco,
I am going to be doing to,
uh,
and also I'm going to be doing a bunch of fucking roadwork before,
before I come up to it.
So I'm going to be extra ready.
Um,
and I actually learned something last time when I did an hour,
basically when I did my half hour,
if HBO was on the road doing 50 minutes,
so to do a half hour,
it was a joke.
It's kind of like if you're doing cardio for 50 minutes and then one day he did
30 be easy.
So,
but what I wasn't doing when I trained for the hour was when I was doing the
hour I was doing right about an hour.
So,
um,
it felt like more work than doing the half hour.
Um,
so this time when I go through,
I'm going to be doing at least an hour and 10 an hour and 15 minutes.
When I'm on stage,
especially September,
um,
September,
October,
November,
I'm,
unless I'm doing three shows that night,
I won't do that cause I don't want to back it up,
you know.
But I got actually I am actually really against doing more than an hour on
stage.
I think it becomes a,
you know,
people are just like all and we got it.
You're funny or we have to go to work tomorrow.
Okay,
my face hurts.
It's like you're overselling.
I always feel like when you do more than an hour,
you're kind of overselling.
Although I did an hour and 13,
I just uploaded that one from San Francisco,
not where you guys can listen,
where I can listen to it and uh,
it actually holds together.
I think maybe a,
I just wasn't in shape enough to do it.
Uh,
but I just,
I don't know.
I just find,
you know,
once you get like an hour,
hour and 15,
it's like,
dude,
enough.
Enough.
All right.
Jesus Christ.
Bill,
let me fucking different ways you're going to answer that.
All right.
Overrated.
Underrated.
Then I'm going to get out of here.
Uh,
okay.
Underrated.
Uh,
Bill Burr.
Thank you.
Lewis.
Black Don Cheadle,
Samuel Jackson Beer.
Real hip hop in parentheses,
common.
Most def to lead quell.
Kweli I don't know who the fuck that is.
A,
yeah,
he is underrated and I have no idea what that is.
Kanye West Kinda.
How are the fuck is Kanye West's underrated?
Uh,
overrated.
Everything on bet.
MTV Vh one.
Sonia cyto mayor.
I don't know who that is.
Barack Obama,
United States military.
I was a marine for five years.
Uh,
J fucking Cutler,
it still won't help the bears for shit.
Um,
you don't actually reminds me,
you know,
something.
I finally,
you know,
I,
I've gotten into some sort of old school like a hip hop,
but I just don't know what the fuck the listen to.
Um,
I've kind of talking like late eighties,
early nineties.
Anything pre biggie if he can,
if he got some shit.
Um,
you know,
and not just obvious shit that they,
Kool moe Dee that they played on like MTV,
like some underground shit like this.
Just stuff that I always hear.
I'll be like,
oh,
you know,
I kind of liked this guy and they'd be,
oh,
he was in leaders of the new school or a,
who's that group Eric sermon was in,
you know,
like if you know any of that shit,
if you can let me know,
give me the heads up on that.
I'd like,
I'd like to download some of that shit cause uh,
I dunno,
I'm into it now.
I'm trying to play drums to it and it's fun again for a challenging.
All right.
Um,
another under really comics are overrated.
Here's an over 81,
and this is what kind of an obscure one,
a comp over a comics who do a visual bit during their specials,
um,
and acknowledged to the live audience.
How funny it is that the CD listeners are left out.
You made a funny face.
We get it.
Yeah.
You know what?
I think I've done that.
Or you're recording a CD and you do a visual joke and then you comment how
everyone at home isn't going to understand that joke.
We're all doing it.
All right.
Um,
last thing asked bill.
Hey Bill just started listening to uninformed last week.
Um,
and that's my,
uh,
show radio show that I do on a Sirius satellite radio,
Sirius Xm,
whatever the fuck they call it.
And you know what?
Somebody just sent me a fucking
a thing here on where the hell you could listen to those
bill.
Read this.
You Fag.
This is like the new thing everyone's doing.
Cause at one guy uninformed,
here we go.
Uh,
all right,
here's where you can listen to all the uninformed shows that,
that I've done with Joe to Rosa,
uh,
for free.
Um,
you can on mini,
mini,
Nova Dotcom,
m I,N ,
I,
mini,
m,
I,
N,
Nova and O v a all lowercase,
no spaces.com.
Uh,
there you go.
You can listen to all of them and we're going to start doing them again.
Uh,
we had one here in July or even when the fuck they even put it out.
Fucking disappointing how disorganized we are with that show.
But anyways,
let's get to ask bill here.
Bill,
just start lists to uninformed week ago.
Um,
I downloaded a package of all the shows done to date,
hence the ancient reference.
Anyways,
uh,
you all cause I said no XM.
Uh,
anyway,
you mentioned a while ago that you were really socially awkward as a kid.
I'd love to hear how you overcame that.
I dropped out of high school at 16,
and it seems the more time I spent alone,
the harder it gets to inject myself into any situation that involves other human
beings.
I'm now 21,
apparently an adult,
but anytime I have to uh,
have to do a task that may involve other people,
it's a real problem.
Even simple things like taking out the garbage or going grocery shopping,
make me shake and sweat.
My situation is probably more severe than yours was,
but I'd love to hear any advice,
uh,
to uh,
to overcome this nonsense.
Um,
all right.
Uh,
okay.
Well,
all right,
where can I start with that shit?
This is all right.
Here's how bad mine was.
I was literally,
I would like be at an ATM and if someone was standing behind me and I had two
transactions,
I would only do one and I would get out of line for fear that the person behind
me,
the second I started the second transaction would literally beat the shit out of
me.
Okay.
Now all this shit is going on in my head because that's how it worked in my
family growing up in now if you took too much time explaining,
I have a bunch of brothers,
so we ended up fist fighting.
But until you verbalize it out loud,
you don't realize how fucking ridiculous it is.
And uh,
so I don't know what did I do?
I basically,
while to become a comedian,
I was in college at the time and what I did was I knew that I could barely give
a book report without my face turned beet red.
So what I did was I just started taking classes,
classes where I knew I'd have to get up in front of the class.
And the more I did it,
the more I enjoyed it and the more it just,
it felt awesome.
So what I would do is,
um,
I dunno,
uh,
I get out a piece of paper,
write out what your fear is.
Like what,
what do you,
what are you thinking is going to happen?
Cause another thing too,
man,
you'll spend your whole life cowering over this great fear that only exists in
your fucking head.
And I swear to God.
And that is most times it's just for some shit,
that APP and when you were a kid and your brain was forming how it was going to
view the world and you just saw some shit or some shit happened to you at the
wrong fucking time.
And then that shit just becomes law in your head as like a five year old,
you know,
and you'll literally 21 years old making dis fearful decisions of a five year
old and a believe me do what I did that.
And I can tell you this,
you know,
you're young enough,
we,
it's Kinda easy to undo that shit,
but if you wait later in life,
like I kind of did it with a lot of stuff.
What it is,
is that little seed of a fucked up thought kinda grows into this big fucking oak
tree that you got to hack down.
So what I would do is,
uh,
you know,
um,
I dunno,
what the fuck can you do?
I don't know what,
I don't know what you do for a living.
I would,
you know,
try to be more social at work.
Try to shoot the shit,
uh,
get involved in something.
If you're good at sports,
join a softball league.
If you play an instrument,
start jamming with other people.
You got to get yourself into the mix of people.
And uh,
you know,
it's Kinda like a,
I knew somebody who really sucked at driving,
you know,
and they were freaking out about it and just sort of,
the more they did it,
it's just like stand up.
If you see I'm sweating,
God,
I would never show you guys these tastes.
But if you could ever see video of when I first started doing standup,
when I got on stage,
I was so fucking nervous.
I never stopped moving the whole time I was on stage.
I will get on stage and I would just pace the entire time.
That would be pouring sweat.
It's like,
it's almost like a performance art or,
or some avant garde cause it doesn't even fucking make sense when you watch it.
I can't believe I ever even gotten any laughs.
But as the years went by and the more shows I did,
the more comfortable I got.
The more presence I could be.
And that's basically how to do it.
But don't be tough on yourself.
Just know you're going to bomb the same way I bombed as a comedian and uh,
I dunno,
find humor in your shortcomings,
you know,
and uh,
just keep working on it.
And uh,
you know,
believe me,
dude,
you're not just going to start talking to somebody in the next day.
You're not going to be,
you know,
shy or whatever.
So give you,
give yourself permission to fuck up for a while as you work your way through it.
Don't do the shit where you kind of say half a sentence and then you get freaked
out and then you stop and then the person's looking at you like,
what the fuck?
And then you feel like a Douche and then you don't try it again until the next
decade.
That's not the way to go.
All right,
you're 21.
You should be out there drinking.
You should be out there banging fucking whores and,
uh,
having a good time because someday you're going to get married.
And even if you have a great marriage,
the level of responsibility and the taxes and what the fucking bankers do to
you,
he life's going to suck.
So,
uh,
yeah,
you can do it.
Do it.
Don't,
don't,
don't fucking,
just don't be too hard on yourself.
That's the biggest thing.
When you're trying to learn new shit,
just know,
give yourself permission to suck at,
at the beginning and then Bam.
There you go.
How's that?
There's a nice feel,
good way to end this podcast.
You know,
I started off the fuck was I talking about coffee,
golf and then a leg sweep and a chick,
you know,
it was looked like it was going to go off the rails and look at it ended very
nicely.
See,
I'm not all bad.
Am I?
All right.
There you go.
Well,
there's your podcast for this week.
I hope you guys enjoyed it.
Uh,
you guys have a wonderful weekend.
If you're in the,
the,
uh,
the Denver area.
Hell if you're in Cheyenne,
Wyoming,
why don't you drive down and come down to my show and,
uh,
I was going to,
going to say,
I'll have a drink with you,
but I can't,
I got to fucking see.
I got to stay on point here.
I'll have a SAS Barilla with you.
I think I'll be doing like fucking cranberry juice and lime.
Is that what the fuck I'm going to do?
Jesus is going to be fucking brutal.
All right.
You guys have a good week.
And uh,
that is all.
Hey Dan,
the new segment is the,
the nominees for youtube clip or the year,
or maybe we'll do other month,
whatever.
We'll work it out.
All right guys.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible].